if you're single and you're looking for
a date the last couple of years have
been tough because of this pandemic they
say according to one recent survey 63
percent of americans who are single and
looking say it's gotten a whole lot
harder matchmaker maria is doing what
she can to help her real name is maria
avigatis she's a fourth generation
matchmaker so she knows a thing or two
we think who's become famous on social
media for her dating advice she says she
has set up more than 5 000 dates and
helped thousands of singles find their
match she's also host to the podcast ask
a matchmaker and ceo of agape match good
morning to you matchmaker maria i'm so
glad you're here i'm so glad you're here
so what do you think is the biggest
mistake men and women
when men and women make i always think
on a first date you always have to play
that very tedious game of getting to
know you
which is just so draining i think and
exhausting what's the biggest mistake
both sexes make i think the biggest
mistake people put is the emphasis on
having a spark on the first date which
can be
varied based on how you're sitting next
to each other what you're talking about
and also do you look like the photos if
you met through online dating
what i always tell people is that the
purpose of a first date is to go on a
second date and to determine that you
should ask yourself two questions
did i enjoy myself am i still curious
about them if you say yes to both of
those questions you should go on a
second date so you say forget about
finding the spark because i always think
you should kind of click right away you
say no no because spark is usually
rooted in anxiety and think about the
few times that you may have felt the
spark and it still didn't go anywhere
yes right so that clearly that's not
working as like a method of trying to
figure out okay is this the person for
me
would you say curious about this person
do you mean curious to keep chatting or
curious to tear each other's clothes off
i mean that's part of the game
okay both like where is it yeah they
don't have to be exclusive right no it's
not mutually exclusive it could be both
i've set up as gail said i've set up 5
000 first dates more than 5 000 first
states at this point and one of the
things that we see sometimes is that
people will go on a fantastic first date
it'll be three hours long but they don't
want to see each other again why it's
not for lack of spark it's not because
they weren't attracted to each other
usually it's because excuse me usually
it's because i i got everything i needed
to know from them i'm good should people
trust their head their heart or
region more southern
so one of the things that i tend to
promote is not having
sexual relations or sex rather right
away when you first start dating someone
because i think that can be a
distraction in getting to know someone
from an emotional compatibility
standpoint
what qualifies as right away i never
think sex on a first date is good under
even if i wanted to i wouldn't just on
gp because i remember my grandmother
saying why
he won't buy the cow if he can get the
milk for free i never thought of myself
as a cow but i do think that there's
something about that do you
so i think one of the things that i
popularized is the 12-day rule method uh
what's your definition of a date which
what dates is yeah people think twelve
days is a lot but it's really two and a
half weeks for most people okay so to me
a date is anything that is excuse me a
phone call a video call or an in-person
date that is 20 minutes to three hours
you can have up to two dates in one day
and this method is a way to make you
intentionally get to know someone to
discover are you emotionally compatible
before going to the next step
one of the things that um
i think in in that method is
seeing that you might not get to 12
dates with people because you'll
recognize they don't really treat me
well when i'm having a good day or when
i'm having a bad day or i don't know if
they're necessarily emotionally
resilient enough for me and it takes
away the distraction of sex so one of
the things you also help people with
their digital profiles i mean we were
saying earlier i we didn't date in the
era of apps well i did but i always
prefer being out there in the wild right
the thrill of victory the agony of
defeat like that's just the part that's
the part that i like digital i i don't
think i look good on paper so you
first of all you definitely do i don't
think so i don't think i would rate on
paper you do but you experienced analog
dating and you were mentioning before we
started uh
taping i guess um about that your nephew
is 18 and he's never experienced analog
dating and he probably never will
because his generation has only known
digital dating so you know with that
being said yes we do take over as a
matchmaking service we obviously do
traditional matchmaking but we also have
an online dating management service
where we take over online dating profile
experience none of the dating fatigue
let
i do like that
asking for a friend how much do you
charge
we'll talk about that later what what's
their
we've been promoting all morning about
you say we're the color green why is
that i'm wearing now tony is wearing a
porsche wow yes yes
i when i when i was single and before
even in dating whenever i wear green i
noticed that everyone comes and talks to
me i've been promoting it since 2012 in
our programs like women you have to wear
green because it is the color vitality
and it is the color that makes you feel
like you are approachable so as a result
whenever you wear green people say oh my
god you look good men remember that you
wore green if you're a straight woman
and i think it's a color of the color
you should be wearing on first dates the
color you should be wearing when you're
at a networking event and absolutely the
color you should be wearing when you're
at the open bar at a wedding where you
can meet other single people okay
and again really how much do you charge
i'm serious we'll talk about it later
you don't want to say
after 12 meetings she'll tell you that
okay all right i am matchmaker maria
thank you very much it's been a pleasure
that sounds like it's expensive please
come back